[Music]
how are you typing exercise together
good this is maybe a companion robot
that looks after patients at home she's
here to remind us mainly about our
medications it's a face you may want to
remember because maybe or something like
it might look after you one day hey I
really she's a robot but in a way like
you actually feel that she cares you
know like she said I'll call your doctor
and that's like something that a friend
would do for you as we live longer and
our aging population strains the health
care system AI and robotics may fill the
gaps we don't have enough people to
provide the level of care that we'd like
to and so that's really where robotics
and AI come in but are we ready to hand
over life and death decisions to the
machines let's start with maybe from
Cattleya health okay so it's cute if a
little bit unsettling but what can it do
well it can't change the sheets or give
you a bath but thanks to innovations in
AI it can monitor your health send
encrypted data to your doctor and even
read the emotions on your face but as
personal health care BOTS become more
advanced will they take over for human
caregivers it's really not about
replacing those people but augmenting
them so that ultimately they can do a
better job at managing a large number of
patients that's all
Corie kids been working on healthcare
robots for more than a decade maybe is
his latest this robot is not making a
diagnosis it's not recommending
treatment that's still something that
the doctor is doing once the patient has
that diagnosis and has been given a
treatment this device is helping
patients stick with that the spread of
technology into more of our personal
lives is alarming to some but not Maxine
Duncan I believe in the new technology
that's regime we have the robot and how
is school today
Maxine and her partner Bert live at the
Heritage downtown
a senior living community in Walnut
Creek California they're currently
testing out a new telepresence robot
from Omni labs the robot is called Jimmy
and now the whole family calls him Jimmy
name stuck
Jimmy keeps them connected to the
outside world and provides a sense of
companionship that Maxine says is a
vital people can call in on it
and then they're right there in the room
with you that's very important and as
you get to be older but the focus isn't
just on elder care AI and robotics and
making advances across the healthcare
industry from genetic testing and
robotic surgery to cancer research and
data collection soon enough you may even
run into some AI in the exam room
finding the melanoma is like trying to
find the needle and the stack of needles
dermatologist Roberto Novoa is using an
AI algorithm to help identify skin
cancer
it's basically comparing that lesion to
the hundreds of thousands of other
lesions that it's looked at the
technology is an experimental mobile
version of an algorithm that was
modified by a team of Stanford grad
students what we've built here is an
algorithm that using a single picture
can distinguish between benign and
malignant skin conditions ai expert
Sebastien thrum led their team so what
this can do is it can bring diagnosis to
your home just take out your phone take
a little image and get as good a
Diagnostics that you would get if equal
to the doctor so how did they do it
oddly enough it all started with dogs
thousands and thousands of them the way
we trained these algorithms is we show
them many many example cases from a
particular object class so for instance
in the case of dogs we'd show it lots of
examples of dogs and then we would test
it and understand how effective it is at
recognized
by showing it new examples that it's
never seen before couple dermatologist
approached us and they said listen if
artificial intelligence can distinguish
between hundreds of breeds of dogs it
might be able to do something for skin
conditions in a test the algorithm
matched the performance of 21
board-certified dermatologists it was
also much faster
scanning skin images at about 200 times
the rate of a human with sufficient data
I think that they will outperform the
majority of humans but there is concern
in the medical community about relying
too much on technology if we get it
wrong and make the wrong diagnosis
people can be harmed terribly and even
can can die in 2013 the team a dr.
Robert walked us Hospital allowed a
dosage error to make its way through
their computer alert system we gave a
kid a 39 fold over dose of a common
antibiotic the correct dose was one pill
we gave this kid 39 pills the patient
ended up spending a week in the
intensive care unit and just through
dumb luck lived and it happened because
of a glitch in the system and a glitch
between the system and the humans that
were using it well he admits that the
industry is safer overall since going
digital doctor Walter says AI and
robotics won't completely take over
health care anytime soon I think for a
patient who is worried that what they
have might be cancer to hear that from a
piece of technology I don't know that
that's what we want
Maxine Duncan may have embraced her
robot Jimmy but she agrees that humans
still have the edge in at least one
category I can't see it replacing humans
because it doesn't give you hugs and it
doesn't give you the feel of being close
to someone
[Music]